you know if this place is a client
that's why we could get a table so
last-minute
that's why they gave us this bigger
table I imagine we'll send some
complimentary stuff to $55 for a steak
known for their meat here than $35 for a
salmon get the salad to blow you for
that price imperiled Meyerowitz the son
Matthew
yes mrs. Danny also felt my relaxes son
I didn't realize you have two sons and a
daughter okay here it'll be nice to
spend time with Deb no I didn't get a
lot of time with him throwing us
his posture Emily they take all of them
of birds and deep-fry them and just pump
pump it's very sad
there are no little birds that in Italy
anymore they've eaten them all
you are going to meet a lot of
interesting people that didn't make it a
month of college because I like joy so
much
[Music]
we're Harold meyerwitz you're on the
list for the public viewing right now
this is a private dealers in the state
hello this is [ __ ] yeah but she
hears everything you're saying
[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen gene run
yeah that's how she runs
[Applause]
[Music]
worried
[Music]
soon
[Music]
[Music]